my music is like your relief it's for
the houses for the girls for the does
for the marriage is for everybody you
know I'm saying I'm playboy Carty I'm in
musician from Atlanta I'm 23 years old
no more stages it's full metal rocking
out this race and I just let my fancy do
whatever the case distances it's us it's
all we got
living in Atlanta everything else around
about it just was a big influence I was
listening to like gucci mane and a lot
of like atlanta oh geez
so like it wasn't hard to find a street
of once I got to it I'll just stay down
[Music]
minute I got someplace and then I got at
least like thousand plays that that gave
me the momentum you know saying just low
we'd be the low share in life and just
kept going so as time went by and the
bigger guy he didn't hit me cuz I was
already into my set just keep going
[Music]
my mind is everywhere with it kind of
fashion no boundaries like just do I'm
from a landing like you know we kind of
country out there so it's good to be
different I wanted to do the fashion I
want to do in movies I want to write a
book I want an amusement park know
everything I'm hungry yeah yeah